ولدت قبل ساعات فقط في بولندا ، أصبحت
أديلينا بالفعل أحد الناجين
من الحرب في
أوكرانيا ، هل من الصعب أن تكون
سعيدًا هل من الصين إنها تقول إن
أديلينا هي أول طفل لكريستينا بافلوتشينكو
أنت تشعر بالذنب
لماذا
لأنني تركت منزلها وتقول إنها غادرت منزلها  في
غرب أوكرانيا
، بدأت الحرب قصفًا بالقرب
من مدينتهم ، وهرب بافلوشينكو بالحافلة ،
ثم سار على الأقدام عبر الحدود ،
وهرع المسعفون إليها إلى المستشفى ، حيث
قامت بتسليم أديلينا قبل شهر
من الانفصال عن عائلتها ماما
والدتي ،
وشقيقتي ، والأجداد الذين لا يزالون
في أوكرانيا.  الأشخاص الذين
تقولهم عن فلاديمير بوتين ، كيف يمكن لأي شخص أن يكون قاسياً للغاية ،
أشعر بالرعب من أن شيئًا كهذا
يمكن أن يحدث بحيث يمكنك أن
تعيش حياتك اليومية وفجأة
بسبب قرارات ليس لديك أي
تأثير عليها.
الحرب وعليك الفرار
، إنه أمر لا يصدق ، إنه أمر مرعب
الدكتورة ماجدا دوتش طبيبة نفسية في
مستشفى إينفلانكا التخصصي في
وارسو ، المستشفى التي تركز على علاج المرضى.
لقد شاهدت فأل 80 مريضًا أوكرانيًا هذا
الشهر أنجبوا 11 طفلاً وعالجوا
مرضى السرطان مثل تاتيانا ميخائيلوك البالغة من العمر 58 عامًا ،
يجب أن تكون هنا ،
ركضت مع حفيدتي بين ذراعي
، وتقول إن الصواريخ قد فجرت
بالفعل النوافذ في مبناهم أثناء
فرارهم من شيء ما  انفجرت بالقرب من
سيارتهم ، مدينتها الآن يشغلها الروس.
إنها ممتنة لأطبائها في
المستشفى والرعاية الصحية المجانية في
بولندا التي تعالج سرطان عنق الرحم.
كريستينا هي واحدة من الأطباء الذين
لا نستخدم اسمها الأخير لأنها
هي نفسها  أيضًا لاجئ من أوكرانيا ، وأم لطفل يبلغ
من العمر خمس سنوات
وزوجة رجل عسكري أوكراني ، وزوجك
مرحبًا يا فطر ، زوجي يعمل
في الجيش منذ عام 2014 في الوقت الحالي
وهو في حالة العيش ، لا يمكنني الجلوس ولا أفعل
شيئًا  تقول إن لدي هذه الفرصة
هنا لمساعدة النساء اللواتي يهربن من البلاد
مع كل نفس.
حبيبي أديلينا تقدم لوالدتها فترة راحة
من الحرب ماذا ستخبر ابنتك
عن ولادتها؟
الحقيقة التي تقولها سنخبرها
بكل شيء كما كان
عليها أن تعرف الحقيقة
لك